Project is a project that our mission
statement is to reconnect the world back
to Allah through salah. This very
charity that you guys believed in gave
the amount of your donations came under
attack. A Muslim attacking another
Muslim. A Muslim attacking another
Muslim's livelihood. A Muslim attacking
another Muslim charity that is serving
the religion. Yes. Yes. You you heard me
correctly. From a fellow Muslim.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was.
>> The first process of an entire
production. So the design comes in,
people look at the design, process the
design, send the design to the next
step.
>> You know, Albanian, we didn't find
anyone to translate it and I had to take
the initiative and translate it with the
AI and and that someone has checked it
and they said it's it's fine.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. The work that was
was showing you at the beginning, it
gets transferred to that computer over
there where it starts transferred to
this machine that prints it out onto the
paper. This is the first phase of
printing. This process is called
transfer print. A lot of people use it
on t-shirts, bags, and everything. It's
a very quick way and it's a very durable
way. Once they are printed, they come
down and then they they are in a roll
and that roll up is going to be
transferred to the machine which we're
going to take you to now in order to be
printed on the actual material. The
transfer paper is being printed on the
actual material. This is the material
that they're using, the velvety
material. Incredible process, brothers
and sisters. It takes a lot of teamwork.
It's a lot of people working here. This
is what is required in order to print
out 50,000 prayer brothers and sisters
in seven different languages. Subhan
Allah.
>> The material gets transferred here where
it will be cut. If you see how many
manpower it takes, you will think it
just like one easy thing. But look at
the manpower behind this how it takes.
It has got to be precise. Exactly
precise.
>> I've only seen something like this on
the internet or on on on TV to be here
and and witness this. Brothers and
sisters, this is from Allah. The fact
that Allah has given us the ability to
find something like this to serve the um
in this way. Subhan Allah. Brothers and
sisters, where there's a wool, there's a
way by the permission of Allah. So in
here after the cut, then it will be
transferred to one of these machines
whereby it's going to be plated and sewn
on the edges. Before going into the
pack, they have to check to check the
quality of the sewing. From what we can
see, it's absolutely neat. And I like
this kind of difference of colors. The
change of colors on the edge. It gives
it it makes it stand out a lot.
>> I'm so happy that we chose this color.
It's absolutely fantastic.
>> It's beautiful. So there's a level of
quality control that takes place in.
>> Yes. This is the final product. Final
product before being packed.
And as you can see, brothers and
sisters, here we are. It's done, packed,
ready to be given. There you go, D.
Brothers and sisters, what you have just
seen, it's not the whole of the 50,000.
That's just part of it. The 35,000 ones
that were printing in English, that was
all the English ones because they were
waiting on us to confirm with them the
spellings of the other languages. But
what you have just seen 35,000
being produced. I mean in there there
are hundreds but I don't know how they
going to I don't know what 50,000
35,000 looks like.
>> Once that is done and it's fully packed
it was it be going into these boxes in
amount of 100
per per box. Yeah. So can you imagine
the amount of boxes that is? That's
absolutely huge brothers and sisters.
Absolutely huge. Just
>> alhamdulillah the team in China are
doing an amazing job. They've gone there
with a mission brother and sisters to
make sure that a man of the donation
that you've given us is going into the
right places and we get the mats for
absolutely much cheaper. Now brothers
and sisters, you guys know me. Some call
me Ali Mawa, some calls me Ali Drama.
And says save the drama for your mama.
Jokes aside, I want to share or
something that we've been hiding from
you guys collectively as a charity for a
long time. The Salah Project is a
project that our mission statement is to
reconnect the world back to Allah
through Salah. This very charity that
you guys believed in gave the amount of
your donations came under attack. I'll
spare the full story for another time.
But in a nutshell, here is what
occurred. By Allah subhana t's
permission and thanks to you amazing
donors, we printed 30,000 m. The mat did
its job and we had no problem. But to
us, it's the objective of teaching
people how to pray salah. But the prices
were so expensive. We had no choice but
to haggle with them because it's your
donations. We could have come and say,
"Who cares? We'll just dish out." No,
your donations. We wanted to go further.
So it's a that carries on for your when
we in 2024 did our fundraising campaign
and told them if you don't give us a
decent price we're going to go and print
our own ones we have no choice but to
because for our donors it's not personal
I'm a trustee I'm a volunteer I don't
get a single penny but this is not about
profit it was an absolute categorical n
you have to order from us and we thought
on what basis can you tell us that we
have to order from you when we don't
have to we got some intermediaries we
said let's come to a solution on our
launch code page we said this year in
2024 we're going to put 2020 20,000
more. The brother who's doing the
indigery, he said, "You know what, Ali,
they do have a point. You didn't mention
in the launch good in 2024, you will be
printing 20,000 more." And they said,
"You know what? No problem. That's the
hub. Even though we don't want to, if we
said that, we have to abide by what we
said. You have to be sticking to your
principle what the word of a believer
says." Said, "No problem. No ego here.
We will do the last order." I said, "Can
you at least give us a discount? This is
the donor's money." He did agree and
said said, "Yes, we will price match it.
If you go and find a cheaper one in
Turkey, whatever, we will price match."
I said, "Okay, I appreciate it. Thank
you. And said going forward you can
order from wherever you like. The very
following day I get a phone call and I
have been told this brother a Muslim.
Yes. Yes. You you heard me correctly
from a fellow Muslim has gone back on
his word saying nope. He's spoken to
shareholders. We are not price matching
and we're going to stick to the original
price not even a discount. Basically was
in a nutshell. We are punishing you for
not ordering from us again. I want to
give a disclaimer that the brothers from
Australia were absolutely fine and
beautiful. Alhamdulillah with the way
they dealt with it. We are talking about
the new owners of this map project that
we used to buy from. Guess what happens?
Allah subhanaa tala makes me realize
when did I place this order? When did I
make the first deposit? I scroll to my
message with the old previous supplier,
the good brother may Allah bless him. I
was going the 25th December, 26th
December, 27th December, 28th December.
I still haven't made a payment and I was
like, "Oh Allah, please let me make this
payment in 2024." the 2nd or the 3rd of
January 2024 of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
look what happens when a Muslim becomes
greedy talking about the donors but
doesn't give a damn about the donors
first few days in 2024 January I made
the first deposit payment of £62,500
to their account said what we're
printing those mats from Turkey 2024 I
made the deposit in 2024 and I made the
second deposit of 62,500 after Ramadan
man in 2024 of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and once we gave that fact to him what
did happened we went silent after that
we thought that's it no it wasn't it so
we left that behind us and said Ramadan
is coming we've been distributing these
mats across Europe UK opening salah hubs
we've got video footage of using the
mats because we're going to use it on
our Ramadan campaign to show people
where their donations went on our old
mat you'll see that it's a joint venture
our logo is at the bottom as well as
theirs just imagine guys we do live
appeals every single day I barely saw my
family. Miss Dar was with them for 30
days straight. Went to Mecca for the
last 10 nights. Subhan Allah.
Fundraising as we are doing this. My
YouTube channel gets strikes. Thank God
it was only two strikes. One more
strike. My channel is shut down. My
livelihood is attacked. Fundraising. I
can't fund raise. We raise alhamdulillah
bulk of our donations for the charity in
Ramadan every single day. Tired is the
work till fudger and we're being
attacked. My channel's got strike. I'm
speaking to YouTube. I don't know what's
going on. and they are basically
striking us because we're using
apparently their mats where it has our
logo at the bottom which is a joint
venture and we've made it clear we're
fundraising we are not printing these
mats anymore this is just an example
we're printing our own mass the fact
that we did not buy from them a Muslim
attacking another Muslim a Muslim
attacking another Muslim's livelihood a
Muslim attacking another Muslim charity
that is serving the religion the videos
that we had that we would use to show
people on the live appeals we couldn't
use any of If you've noticed in the
videos, we would have to plaster our new
design that we made hazardly so we can
show people what they're donating
towards. All of this pressure from
another Muslim to another Muslim all
because of profits. All because of
money. The team knows what we had to go
through. It was hard. Well, with
hardship comes these. Alhamdulillah. Now
we know the effort, the sweat, tears
that we put into this. Guess what? We
get it for 75% cheaper. For the sake of
Allahhana and for you donors, we fought
this battle and alhamdulillah we raised
nearly £270,000. We still raised it and
now we get our masks for 75% cheaper and
it's a better quality. And I'm not going
to mention this organization because
they are also even though if it's for
profits or whatever, people still
benefit and I don't want that benefit to
stop. I don't want to do what they've
done to us over profit, over ego, over
whatever. Our old suppliers would have
charged us £33,000 so they can fill
their pockets with profits. We decided
to cut that to £78,000. Your donation
saved so your donation go further. And
we're not doing this to be praised or
act like, you know, we need a cookie.
Just to show you the reality of what's
really going on. The brothers are in
China and it's all smiling and funky,
etc. Alhamdulillah, may Allah bless
them. But just know behind the scenes,
the blood, sweat, and tears we had to go
through to get it to that process that
we're in China and we're printing them
for 75% cheaper. That this is something
us and you donors, we went through it
together. We could have easily come and
say, you know what, don't want to go
through this struggle, etc. We have the
donations, we'll just give it. No, it is
our duty and a manner that you trusted
us with that we will fight for it. And
we did that brother and sisters even
though you guys were not aware and I
don't want to take away from the whole
amazing China trip and I want you guys
to know that we went through the
hardship and those smiles of those
brothers inhab and rswan going to China
finding the factory doing due diligence
alhamdulillah work with the factory
building relationships that you guys
have embarked on this journey with us
inshallah you've seen the happy times
the times of struggle the times of
hardship I'm going to go get you guys to
go back to China inshallah and enjoy the
China vlog brothers and sisters and many
more vlogs are going to come where we
show you guys and take you on a journey
with us of how we are managing your
funds and making sure that we're
reconnecting the world back to Allah
through the Salah Project. Inshallah
download the app inshallah. This project
is only going to grow further inshallah.
May Allah bless you for your support in
brother and sisters. But back to China.
>> We had such we finally made it to China.
As you can see behind me, it can't get
more Chinese than this.
>> But chef, are we here for designer
shopping?
>> No dou. Are we here for food? Chef
>> Dwood. No dou. Are we here for tourism,
Sher?
>> No, D.
>> We're not.